Cyclone Freddy battered Mozambique twice
in a matter of days destroying more than
130 homes and displacing an estimated
184 000 people water facilities clinics
and medical centers were damaged
accelerating the spread of Cholera while
the cholera outbreaks regularly occur
Mozambique between October and April of
every year with more than 21
000 cases currently in 95 tests this is
the largest outbreak in the last 20
years
it's not only cholera the World Health
Organization is also warning of a
looming hunger crisis
the UN estimates about 3.1 million
people are in need of food assistance
access to Safe water and sanitation is
still challenging and about one-third of
the crops have been destroyed
for Mozambique climate change is not a
future problem the effects of prolonged
severe weather patterns are already
evident Lena awake Al Jazeera